ce pôle temps divisé québécois avec
certains mots le débat dure depuis des
mois le parti libéral et québec
solidaire presse le gouvernement de
reconnaître l'existence du racisme
systémique mais le premier ministre
nader pas au concept racisme individuel
structurelles puis systémique c'est aux
états unis qu apparaît d'abord
l'expression d'un concept wii qui est
proposé à la fin des années 60 par des
militants afro américains cependant la
sociologie du racisme elle s'inscrit
dans tous les pays du monde le concept
revient à l'avant plan dans la foulée du
mouvement black ice man il est repris au
canada comme ailleurs pour dénoncer des
inégalités persistantes qui ne sont pas
le fait d'individus précis quand on
approche du raciste qui est systémique
on se limite pas effectivement essayé de
traquer le raciste dans des discours
individuels ou dans des actes
individuels on met en cause aussi le
rôle des institutions des lois parfois
doit pénaliser de façon disproportionnée
certains certains groupes il donne en
exemple les difficultés particulières
d'accès au logement ou à l'emploi
auxquels font face les membres des
minorités visibles
pour moi le racisme systémique ou
structurel et
désigne une réalité qui est importante a
nommé mais le terme ne fait pas
consensus certains le trouvent un
imprécis il ya aussi une hésitation
vraiment scientifique
quand on parle de racisme systémique
qu'elles groupe est ce qu'on met dans
cette méta catégorie et quels sont les
critères les critères pour déterminer
qui en fait partie et qui n'en fait pas
partie est ce que c'est la couleur est
ce que c'est la religion dans le
contexte politique québécois c'est en
2016 que les mots discrimination et
racisme systémique se fraye un chemin
des groupes de la société civile réclame
une commission denquête des références
au concept apparaissent dans les débats
à l'assemblée nationale la commission
des droits de la personne mène des
consultations le rapport revient sur les
relations entre les autochtones et les
services publics québécois il fait aussi
référence il me semble un poids ce
denier
discrimination systémique mais le débat
reste figé le gouvernement et les partis
d'opposition campent sur leurs positions
le débat s'alimente lui même et au final
on obtient on obtient des en fait des
camps qui ne s'écoute pas et qui ne
cherche pas à le valider ce qui l'aurait
d'historiquement juste un dans les
arguments qui sont avancées de part et
d'autre il ya une instrumentalisation
politique des deux côtés du spectre
idéologique et autant fédéral qu'au
provincial on est enlisé dans une guerre
de mots et on en a perdu on l'a perdu de
vue les objectifs les premiers ministres
du canada et de nombreuses autres
provinces par de racisme systémique
depuis longtemps déjà pourquoi le
gouvernement québécois est il plus
hésitant il ya des réactions très
défensive qui s'explique dans la mesure
où le nationalisme québécois a souvent
été des pets dans le canada anglais
comme étant intrinsèquement raciste
comme si les affaires de manière si
l'actuel premier ministre reconnaissait
le racisme systémique c'était comme
s'ils venaient j'espère validé
finalement les préjugés de l'extérieur
du québec
le débat se poursuit des institutions de
la société québécoise comme le spvm et
la ville de montréal ont décidé
d'utiliser l'expression tout comme le
collège des médecins est l'ordre des
infirmières et infirmiers ici hugo
lavallée radio canada québec